destiny is a game with many many players
that cost too many many dollars to make
and it's been generally very successful
but it's not without its problems and
one of those problems is its lackluster
story but can we really call it a
problem when the game has been such a
huge commercial success and if it is
still a big issue why hasn't it impacted
upon the game's popularity the game
player versus plot debate is a tale as
old as time but with super successes
like destiny that have been accused of
having a story that's actually worse
than Twilight you have to wonder if
story matters all that much when the
gameplay is still engaging players first
up let's chat about whether Destiny's
story really matters or not it's worth
mentioning that Bungie certainly didn't
set out to make destiny all about the
gameplay and light on story in fact in
bungees founding statements they claimed
to have two goals the first of which
breeds developed kickass games that
combines state-of-the-art technology
with uncompromising art captivating
storytelling and deep gameplay with
review after review touting the Destiny
missed the mark on that captivating
storytelling bit though what does it say
about what it is gamers are really after
given that destiny has an average of 3.2
million players logging on every day
gamers seem to slot themselves into a
few different categories those who
prioritize gameplay or the story those
who enjoy detailed narrative worlds even
if the gameplay is a little lacking and
those who don't want their games to have
any weak links it's worth then looking
at whether a weak link can take down a
game evidently Destiny's soso story
hasn't heard its success too much and we
see the same sort of thing in the
critical success of middle-earth the
shadow of Mordor whose gameplay far
outshines its plot comparatively
story-driven games that don't deliver on
gameplay rarely find themselves in the
triple-a spectrum one example is 2012
spec ops the line which went all in
it's heavy Apocalypse Now asks story but
on the pendant with uninspired
third-person shooter gameplay although
some people argue that was the point
the basic gameplay was crucial to the
storytelling but it still left some
gamers with a bad taste in their mouths
as a result it's difficult to compare
the mutual success of games that
prioritize story and fail on gameplay
versus games like destiny except to
suggest that the reason we don't see
very many story driven games getting the
backing of big publishers is that gamers
want gameplay first and story second
moreover we're a game with crappy story
but good gameplay can succeed a game
with poor gameplay and a great story is
unlikely to attain commercial success
although they can achieve critical
success in the cases of games like gone
home The Walking Dead and heavy rain
it's worth looking at why destiny didn't
suffer from its crappy story given that
it's been such a prominent criticism and
I think this meme created by a destiny
player is a really good place to start
two weeks ago reddit user Buddhist 32
submitted an image entitled after
hearing all of the destiny hating and
finally beating the last story mission
followed by the text I'm not sure what I
did but I had fun doing it
maybe it doesn't really matter even
Peter Dinklage and Nathan villain
couldn't convince us to care about the
plot the script contains numerous
cringe-worthy phrases such as I don't
even have time to explain why I don't
have time to explain and perhaps the
fact that it's all too silly to care
about works in the favor of players who
are indeed let's just shoot things and
pick up shiny [ __ ] mindset I mean look
at the habló three Reaper of souls
despite blizzards love of cinematic
cutscenes the base game wouldn't have
benefitted from a media story
it needed optimized gameplay features
the inclusion of special loot filled
rifts and unlimited level caps to entice
players back I doubt that many people
decided to pick up Diablo 3 again to
play the extra story bits particularly
when Blizzard improves on the gameplay
so drastically for gamers who loved the
grind and loot chase
that's a very similar reason to why
destiny players continue to return to
the universe every day Oh
3.2 million of you as much as everybody
mutually agrees that Destiny's story
isn't anything to write home about
destiny has been sold and promoted
primarily as an always online
multiplayer FPS where the title concerns
our loot and shooting noobs in the face
to get that loot and most gamers seem to
be happy to take it for what it is which
suggests the perhaps Destiny's lack of
engaging story doesn't matter all that
much the overall experience at least not
to those of you who've enjoyed it but
let me know what you think gherkin
destiny is allowed to have a weak story
or should games like this work hard to
be good in every aspect leave me your
thoughts and I will catch you next week